All right. So, I wanted to create a tool
for DGER who are thinking about leaving
the best orbit. With Ryan Beard's video
clocking 1 hour and 30 minutes, the
Wan's brain of your average DGER will
not make it. I have created a more
condensed version to assist in the
deprogramming. Let's start with him
leaking explicit images for two separate
girls. They dug should like, what do you
got to say about these logs? I heard um
I found out that you leaked nudes of a
girl. Like dude, there have been threads
on this. This has been in the news. Like
everybody knows this, dude. You're not
finding out anything new about me. Like
understood that you showed private
pictures of her to two of your friends.
Yes. Yes. Okay. So that's part of it. In
2012, when Destiny was 23, he shared in
a group chat with a couple of his
friends the messages, "You want to see
the sickest in the world? So many fan
girls." I had one that was 15. She
wanted to meet and hook up. Dude, she's
15. What the? But she sent me pictures
that made it so hard to say no. Then
Destiny linked a picture of this girl in
a bikini in the chat and said, "Girl on
the left, so hard to say no. Going to
get arrested one of these MLGs, man."
Thank you, Ryan Beard. Destiny also
shared explicit photos of a troll's high
school sister to intimidate him. And so
that was cute. So I got on Google Voice
and I gave him a call via Google Voice.
And I was like, "Hey, what's up, bro?"
And he's like, "Whatever, dude." He's
like, "So you can Google. That's pretty
cool that you got my phone number or
whatever. He must think you're like
super pro or whatever." And I'm like,
"No way, dude. I just wanted to talk to
your dad or maybe your brother Jeremy or
your sister Emma." He's like, "Dude,
that's not even like my family." And I
was like, "Oh, are you sure, dude?" And
he's like, "Yeah, man." I was like, "Oh,
really?" And so I start sending him
pictures over Skype of his sister, like
I guess on the volleyball team. I got a
ton of information on this kid. Like I
know more about his family than I know
about mine. It's pretty funny. Um, so
he's like, "Whatever, dude. So you can
Google my name. Like congrats. You're
pro." 10 years later, that kid came
forward to tell his story. And he's he's
saying, you know, calling me, you know,
telling me my address, telling me that
he's, you know, got friends, and that
he's thinking about buying a gun, coming
to my house, and that he knows where my
sister goes to school, and that he's
going to come drive to my house. He's
going to murder me, my father, my
brother, my sister, and my mother. and
he's gonna rap my mother and my sister
and record all of it. Destiny shared
explicit videos of fellow streamer Pixie
without her consent and is currently
being sued by her in federal court. He
also distributed videos of his then wife
Molina without her consent.
Um
well something I can't like I'm not
going to go into detail of anything but
there's plenty of people that's
wondering this but I feel like it should
be obvious. Um nothing has happened with
consent with anyone. Not me and not
anyone else. Like like there's been no
consent. So that's something that people
seem to wonder about and I feel like
that's something that people should
know. I guess that's it. Oh, anyone
saying stuff like that? That's like
actual revenge. Um so no thank you. It's
it's not anything like that. So thank
you. That's something else that
happened.
Um, yeah, that was really horrible.
Actually, really horrible. I take that
very seriously. U, so anyone commenting
about that stuff because it's an actual
traumatic experience, they're going to
they're going to get instantly and never
met ever. 4 years prior, Destiny
admitted he shared Molina's nudes
without her consent. Okay, so a long
time ago. So sometimes, so obviously,
okay, me and Mina send nudes to people.
Um, me and Mina had a conversation about
there were a few girls we talked to. I
was like, "Oh, cool. Like we should
record videos of like usage people. Like
it's fun." So we do this. Um, I kind of
like have like my little archive of like
material that I'll send to people if I
want to. Um, there were girls that I
talked to um, past that that I'd send
stuff of like either me or me and
Molina. And Molina talked to me and she
was like, "Hey, um, if you're going to
send any videos to um, new girls that we
haven't talked about, like let me know
that first." Um, because she wanted to
be careful. And I was like, "Okay,
sure." That was fine. I didn't think of
it at the time cuz I didn't think it
mattered. But if you're going to send
any videos to um, new girls that we
haven't talked about, like let me know
that first. um because she wanted to be
careful. Okay, sure. That was fine. I
didn't think about it at the time
because I didn't think it mattered. But
I didn't think about it at the time
around the end of 2011, Destiny
assaulted a woman on his live stream.
I'm not using the word allegedly here
because we have video of him doing it
and he has openly admitted that it was
assault. I would say that in my
streaming career in the past, like
totally publicly, like I completely and
totally like assaulted a girl on stream
before for like 5 minutes or whatever. I
got super drunk. Thanks again, Ryan.
Destiny also has multiple victims of
recording instances without consent.
Starting with the Grinder hookup where
you hear Destiny knock on the door all
the way to him leaving and he never
mentions the recording. But I'm trying
to do this one piece at a new leak
dropped on KF recording of the Grinder
dude. That's uh that's
horrifying. That's horrifying stuff.
two uh grinder encounters and then
there's the cherry stuff. The grinder
encounter uh how do you know is
unconceptual?
Uh because you hear him walking up with
his phone in his pocket before he meets
the person and then it's like hey hi and
they don't he never says hey I'm
recording in my pocket. So uh to my mind
if he had sent messages if they had
discussed beforehand uh hey I'm going to
record with my phone in my pocket they
would have there would be records of
that. Yes. Do you know how Grinder
works? Have you ever been on Grinder? I
have not. Okay. So, I'm gay and when I
use Grinder, if I ever redownload the
app or like sometimes like if I was
haven't talked to somebody for some time
that it's just immediately erased. So, I
don't know how he gets lost. So, if you
were planning to share those recordings
with other people, do you think you'd
make an archive of that? Especially as
the guy who archives all of his
conversations. Fellow streamer Cherry
also had recorded without her consent
that leaked. She has filed a police
report in the state of New York. Destiny
has also choked out his girlfriend,
doxed over a dozen people, and made
explicit violent threats to intimidate
potential witnesses.
Yeah. I um for Anna, that's for just I'd
if I could. I'd shut the house and do
it. Um but not for Anna. No people do
her is what you're saying. Yeah. No.
What the like why would I even want to
do that? Like what am I want to kill
her? What? Like that's I do want
somebody to kill though or laugh or so.
There you go. Apparently, what am I
going to dox her? What do I want?
Somebody to kill her. So, that's how he
thinks of doxing, right? Doxing's really
bad, but I'm going to try to dox Jtock
and Queen, right? Doxing's really bad.
You heard that, right? Not for Anna.
Noxer is what you're saying. Yeah. No.
What the Like, why would I even want to
do that? Like, what am I? What? Like, so
if he wanted somebody to kill them, he
would dox them, right? Just to give you
a good idea of why he would do that to
somebody. Even if he went down to hold
her to stop throwing instead of hitting
her, I'm almost 100% sure everyone would
be saying the same. He had to leave her.
He is going, "Yeah, I of course, dude. I
wish I would have filmed my with Rachel.
I wouldn't have any cuz you guys would
probably think I'm a abuser, too."
Garren [__] te cuz you better believe
I had to choke her out a few times. That
got crazy. Hell yeah it did. And I
guarantee you that everybody in here
would probably think I'm a crazy
physical abuser, too. Sure. Destiny also
doxed Anna, a former partner, sending
his fans to harass her. Oh, okay. Also,
heads up, this is my only non-media
blackout time. Okay, this is my only
non- media blackout time over media like
this. Okay, somebody on Kiwi Farms has
made a thread of Anna. So, if you are
obsessed with Anna and you want to talk
about her all the time, you chatter. You
can actually go to Kiwi Farms and you
can go and post all you want, read all
you want. That go there, post about it,
talk about it. People put a lot of
effort into categorizing and archiving
everything. There you go. Okay. And in
the thread about Anna that Destiny
encouraged his fans to go message they
doxed Anna. And it was later revealed
that at this time Destiny was secretly
in an ongoing relationship with Anna. So
you acknowledge that you've been with
her for a year. I think. Yeah, we've had
on and off. Sure. In response to this,
Anna texted Destiny, "You literally
ruined my life. You just doxed me on
your stream. You put me in danger." And
Destiny responded to this by saying,
"You're doing it to yourself, and you're
going to keep doing it to yourself."
Lastly, if this didn't tell you enough
about Destiny, let me show you what his
friends say about him over the last 6
months. All right. Today, we get to talk
about someone I know. Maybe new. I don't
really know how it how it works. I feel
like the term content creator friend is
very gay, but you know, I guess that's
the situation we're in. Obviously, it's
tough, but
what occurred and what I've seen is
completely and totally
unacceptable and horrible. the
underlying
conduct. My heart, you know, aches
for the victims
involved. It's been a tough
period. I want you to know that
everything I did in the New York studio
situation, you know, I wasn't paid for
any of
that. I did it because I believed in it.
It's a bitter pill to swallow for
sure. And not only
that, I like Pixie
was was a DGER. You know, you see me
wear DGG
hat, wear
DG
emblem, the omni liberal logo.
I mean, it's it's you know what what
stronger confirmation do you need? I
mean, there's there's seemingly no DM
where he outright denies that he did
this. I mean, maybe once again, there's
some missing puzzle piece that I'm
missing. And if that is the case,
obviously, this video is going to be
totally and out of date at the very
least. And I would be more than willing
to make that, you know, public, his his
new response and show that he never did
this in the first place. But
realistically speaking, like Aerodite
said that he did this, Pixie said that
he did this. Destiny seemingly is
acknowledging that he did this and all
the messages. So unless there's some
like grand conspiracy, you know, against
him, there's there's basically like two
outcomes, which is one that he did it,
which is the most likely, and secondly,
he didn't do it, and he is having like a
schizophrenic meltdown or something like
that. I have nothing to gain from being
friends with Stephen. I have literally
had nothing to gain from the moment that
we've known each other. Like, don't get
me wrong, Steven's done a lot of good
things for me personally on the low in
terms of behind closed doors and help me
out with certain things. And I'm always
going to be appreciative of that. And
you know, in that regards, he's been
very stand up for me. And I and I'm
grateful. But professionally, like
outside of that, it's been pretty bad.
Like a lot of people want to stop
working with me. A lot of people want to
complain about the fact. And I never
cared about any of it. Why? Cuz I just
like Steen. I saw him as a friend. So I
was cool with it. I didn't care if
people wanted to stop talking to me. I
didn't care if fans got mad. I didn't
care if people question. Didn't bother
me at all. But when he engages in like
actual behavior that I think is
reprehensible, and I'm like, "Bro, what
are you doing? This is stupid and his
response is, "I like to have fun. I
don't care." Then there's just got to be
a come point where I'm like, "Art, then
I just got to cut you off because your
definition of fun is toxic." You know,
you're not going to be forgiven for this
anytime soon, dude. You're just like
immaturity is just crazy. Yeah, that's
basically the whole situation. Seems
pretty seems like Destiny is a pretty
bad person. Wow. Big shocker. I know
everybody's uh you know, nobody's told
me that before ever. Not one. Not one.
Everybody said he was he was awesome
until this moment. though. But
um I never thought it would
be without
Steven. In all my visions of the future,
I always saw him as
um being by our side
um as we moved on to these
things. I always envisioned it. It's
what I wanted.
But I don't despair because I know some
of you are still out there and and there
are good creators, good people to
follow. It it's certainly not going to
be the same. I'm not telling you it's
going to be the same at
all. But um I'm I'm begging you, please
don't become apathetic. Don't lose
heart.
If you don't mind, I'm going to take a
sip of my iced tea.